[Musique]
michael fortier françoise boivin gel du
cebr a une gueule un bon soir mais soit
bon il ya eu un drame à la boxe mais je
vais quand même emprunter une expression
de la boxe n'est pas une carrière je
pense qu'on peut s'entendre là-dessus
tour de table rapide y a pas un grand
gagnant qui sort de l'exercice de tva
débat face à face je crains c'est que
vous jugez moi je vous dirais que ceux
des balances arrivé le jour même où
étaient où on avait sondage auprès de
3000 québécois québécoise ça c'est
important pour avoir fait dix sept
débats des chefs je peux vous et vous en
tenez compte d'un sondage de cette
importance qui démontrait que le bloc
était 34% chez les francophones les
libéraux 29 et les conservateurs avec
moi je pense que yves françois blanchet
a eu le meilleur débat permettra
peut-être de progresser tout au moins de
maintenir de secours actuel monsieur
trudeau a eu un bon débat mais il n'a
toujours pas répondu à la question si
lutte était majoritaire avec celle
d'être la chaîne élections moi je me
souviens que lors du déclenchement
d'élections sur les hommes ici et dans
d'autres médias j'ai cette question là
va durer la plupart des gens m'ont
répondu ça va disparaître dans 48 heures
cette fois en semaine c'est encore la
déraison et lesquels les québécois et
les canadiens sont franches et de sa
tante et si bien qu'il ya seulement six
pour cent des québécois qui ont une
opinion favorable de monsieur trudeau et
43% défavorable monsieur singh ont pu
s'imposer c'est pas grave pour le québec
mais si fait deux autres débats comme ça
ça peut être grave ailleurs au canada
colombie britannique surtout et en
ontario monsieur autour les t notes je
pense il n'ya pas reculer a pas avancé
mais c'est acheter des problèmes les
armes à feu son discours qu'on vend les
informent sur les transferts en santé il
veut pas répondre et quand il dit qu un
contenu des contrats pour signer en
justement en un contrat signé entre le
fédéral et les provinces sur les
garderies qui refuse de dire qui va le
respecter comme avoir confiance en
quelqu'un qui juge le sien contre eux
mais je pas capable de respecter un
quota qui est des jeux si michael
fortier
vat résumé de la soirée
un bon résumé fse et d'un cycle suivi de
g je pense qu on a eu un départ à la
hauteur hors de la course c'est à dire
une course qui est serré donc on a eu un
débat musclé très intéressant moi j'ai
trouvé très intéressant
oui rapidement pour les chefs je pense
que trudeau où j'ai trouvé sur trudeau
bagarreur de trouver sur ses deux pieds
en avant pas du tout sur la défensive
sauf sur la question du déclenchement
d'élections qui on pourrait revenir
bientôt au tour de la raison le contrat
le plan j'ai un blanc contre eux mais
pour se rappeler au tour lui il voulait
traverser l'épreuve sans perdre de
plumes sans perdre de plumes et moi je
pense qu'au final il peut être réussie
monsieur blanchette jeu pas d'accord
avec eux jugent parfois que c'est lui
qui a gagné parce qu'il a perdu mais son
style on y reviendra aussi ya le fond et
la forme et dans la forme il ya eu
plusieurs d'un père selon moi est le
grand tour f mes grands on invite
quelqu'un va importer donc personnes se
rappellent quand tu retournes à la
maison jeudi il y avait quelqu'un son
divan mieux tu parles et non j'ai pas
parlé c'est exactement ce qui est arrivé
avec ses nuits hier c'était un touriste
à ce débat françoise
jusque d'accord avec maicon sur pas mal
d'un tous là la chose qui est bonne pour
monsieur au tourne c'est qu'on se
retrouve aujourd'hui patrice et se dire
ça ça sa course électorale elle est
manquée il pourra pas s'en remettre puis
tout le monde allume des lampions pour
le débat en anglais en espérant que
qu'on répète pas l'histoire d'un drôle
je pense que c'est un débat qui va
passer dans les annales comme étant un
des plus grands débats j'ai trouvé pour
vous et est heureuse un peu long mais
j'ai trouvé la soirée dimanche passé
beaucoup plus intéressant d'avoir chacun
des chefs un à un art avec vous trois
pour pouvoir vraiment observer comment
thèse qui répondait à une question parce
que de toute façon lyon pas mal dit
ce qu'on a entendu toute la soirée
presqu'en beau que j'avais des fois les
pressions l'expert musée revenir ces
deux formules complémentaires ces deux
formules qu elle aime en terre puis
je débats mais je veux dire ce que je
veux dire c'est ouais ce que je veux
dire par contre c'est que il reprend
choses qui vont rester de ce déballage
et leurs raisons par contre la question
des armes à feu je suis convaincu que
jouer
sous licence par ma faim je vous en
parlais séparément de leur match mais
j'ai deux extraits parce que là
effectivement on a besoin de précisions
j'ai rien vu dans saab régalant de la
soirée d'hier
ils ont tous bien performé nous vivons
un moment beau souligner que c'est pas
toujours d'accord qu'on a quatre chefs
qui peuvent s'exprimer aussi bien en
français que les camions faye assouan
alors je pensais c'était formidable
puisqu'ils ont tous bien performé pour
moi la question devient qui a fist qui
devrait faire dans le contexte actuel
dans la campagne électorale
selon moi c'est probablement plus
trudeau et je vais m'expliquer le débat
via soir continue des performances des
deux qui savent d'avant dans les
sondages au québec pour moi j'analyse
ray que ça veut dire qu'il faut vraiment
pas avoir de voix qui vont bouger c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour credo c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour blanc chez aussi
alors avec les risques et avec la façon
que la campagne allait jusqu'à jusqu'à
ce moment-là je pense que trudeau a
sorti guingamp je suis d'accord que
c'est marie cas assez bien performer il
n'y avait pas beaucoup de substance à
était pas vraiment autant agressifs que
les autres malgré que les outils d
agressif mais qu'en même temps on est
vraiment juste ajouter une chose que
personne n'a dit encore la
piquante hiver alors évidemment c'est
une semaine encore
un peu n'importe et qui semblait avoir
des lancers lors des dernières années 60
tombe à l'eau